usa la calculadora para encontrar el
lugar y tmo en base de 67 hasta
milésimos y bueno
es uno de los números más raros que
existen en matemáticas sin embargo de
los más útiles aparece en la naturaleza
en las finanzas en la economía etcétera
etcétera etcétera etcétera y es cercano
a 2.71 es como 2.71 algo algo algo algo
y al final es un número por eso cuando
yo digo que voy a tomar el logaritmo en
base de 67 esto es lo mismo a tomarme
logaritmo en base de 2.71 de 67 no te
preocupes tanto por el número en el
número es casi cercano a 2.71 algo hielo
y algo lo único que estamos buscando es
a qué potencia tengo que elevar el
parqué m de 67 a qué potencias tengo que
lleva del 2.71 algo al cual valgo para
que me dé 67 y si a esto llamamos x lo
podemos ver en su forma exponencial de
la siguiente manera elevado la equis que
es mi resultado esto es igual a 67 como
te decía a qué potencia tengo que elevar
a él para que me dé 67 y bueno aquí
quiero mencionarte algo muy importante
comúnmente se le conoce como el
logaritmo natural cuando veas log en
base en muchos lo utilizan como el
logaritmo natural cuya abreviación o en
las calculadoras aparece como el n es
decir el n es el logaritmo natural que
no es ni más ni menos que el logaritmo
en base como es un número bastante
importante es importante tener el
logaritmo natural a la mano y lo que
queremos es el logaritmo natural de 67 o
en su dado caso el lugar en un base de
67 y bueno como es 2.71 algo algo algo
que bueno que nos dicen que podemos usar
la calculadora porque realmente yo no sé
a cuánto hay que elevar e para que nos
dé 67 así que vamos a utilizar la
calculadora y bueno yo también tengo
algo de suerte porque aquí tengo una
calculadora texas que es gráfica doran y
además slate y 85 y en estas
calculadoras gráfica dora's casi siempre
uno pone el logaritmo natural y ojo lo
mismo naturales este botoncito que
ahorita te voy a enseñar de 67 sin
embargo no todas las calculadoras hacen
lo mismo
este es el botón de logaritmo natural en
una calculadora como éstas aprietas
logaritmos
de 67 y le pones igual y te daría el
resultado sin embargo no todas las
calculadoras hacen lo mismo
hay algunas no tienes que poner 67
primero y después apretar el logaritmo
natural y te da el resultado pero bueno
en esta se escribe como se lee logaritmo
natural de 67 es 4.204 69 blablabla lo
bueno también es que nos piden que lo
redondeamos a milésimos y este de aquí
es en lugar de milésimas y lo que hemos
redondeado es decir que nos vamos a
fijar al lado que hay hay un 6 y lo
vamos a redondear es decir que nuestra
respuesta sería 4.205 porque estamos
redondeando esto es aproximadamente
4.205 y ya tenemos nuestra respuesta la
cual tiene toda la lógica del mundo
porque fíjate bien el lugar es natural
de 67 es cercano a 4.205 pero yo sé que
todo se eleva a la 4 es esto es 16 y 3
elevado a la 4 es 27 por 3 lo cual es 81
y si te das cuenta es un número que está
entre 2 y 3 por lo tanto 67 tiene que
estar entre 16 y 81 y además tiene toda
la lógica del
porque es cercano a 2.71 y 2.71 su vez
es más cercano a 3 que a 2
por lo tanto 67 se va a parecer más a 81
que a 16 así que esto me suena que está
bien si tomas a él y lo eleva de la
potencia a 4.205 aproximadamente te va a
dar 67